on l'a vu avec la pandémie on s'est rué
vers des aliments de base des oeufs de
la farine mais certains produits ont
presque complètement disparu de notre
alimentation
c'est le cas de la viande de veau
[Musique]
dans l'est de l'amérique du nord la
viande de veau est à 75% un produit
canadien est presqu'à coup sûr provient
d'élevages québécois dont les trois
quarts sont des petits mâles achetés
dans des fermes laitières
la valorisation des veaux de troupeau
laitier a été imaginé au québec
[Musique]
d'abord le veau de lait nourris au lait
avec des fibres et suppléments
protéiques origines qui va donner une
chair tendre de couleur rose pâle c'est
ce que c'est c'est un bien que la fête
protéines de luxe et le vent degrés
d'abord alimenter au lait puis au maïs
avec des fibres est un mélange protéines
et la viande du veau de grain à un autre
aspect rose et rose et rouge - rouge
qu'elle boeuf plus rouge qu'elle vaut de
l'est
tant pour les éleveurs de veaux de lait
que de votre grain la pandémie est une
véritable catastrophe
cette viande pourtant très recherchée ne
seront plus là demain aucune aide
gouvernementale
et en plus je paye pour travailler la
ferme de pierre luc nadeau se trouve à 5
6 d'or dans chaudière appalaches
c'est vous de lait arrive au terme de
l'élevage à 170 jours en quittant les
tables chacun aura pu 2400 litres de ce
lait et mangent et 50 kilos aux fibres
chez louis joseph beaudoin de
saint-séverin en mauricie les trois
sites d'élevage de veaux de grain compte
1800 places
ils sont abattues pluvieux à 210 jours
ils sont prêts à partir ils ont mangé au
moins 600 kg degré chacun un autre
élevage à perte
jo la main l'iphone perdu ont pesé après
30 % note prix
les éleveurs ne trouvent plus preneur
pour leurs animaux parce que le
confinement a fait disparaître les
marchés du veau plus de la moitié
destinée au secteur à cherry donc
hôtel-restaurant institutions c'est la
portion qui nous fait plus mal
actuellement la dans la crise la combine
dans le cas du veau de lait c'est
dramatique
cette viande haut de gamme est presque
entièrement destiné au restaurant dont
la moitié de la viande est exportée sud
jamais vu pour le directeur de la mise
en marché des vouchers les producteurs
de bovins du québec
il n'y a pour l'instant aucune lumière
au bout du tunnel
c'est même phénomène aux états unis les
restaurants sont fermés
les marchés se sont contractés donc
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
d'exporter les veaux vivant ou même les
pièces de vauvert les marchés extérieurs
à partir du 15 mars
des deux côtés de la frontière les
restaurants ont fermé leurs portes
comme retardé l'abattage aurait dénaturé
la viande
il a fallu disposer des veaux de la
restauration toutes les parties qui
étaient destinés à la restauration en
fait qui est tombé à presque rien c'est
parce qu'ils ont été congelés le depuis
depuis le début de la crise un grand
volume de viande disponible et démarche
est anéanti
résultat les prix payés aux éleveurs ont
chuté au mois de février on parlait d'un
prix de 4 dollars la livre en juin 3,35
c'est énorme compte tenu que les marges
bénéficiaires des éleveurs de veaux cpo
c'est pas des marges très très hot
d'avancé besoin bouddhique est
présentement on est dans le rouge
situation d'autant plus difficile pour
pierre luc nadeau depuis 2016
les éleveurs de veaux de lait comme lui
n'ont plus droit à l'assurance
stabilisation des prix
l'asra il perd 300 $ par animal vendu
présent demain cage à one 22 vos ses
environs sa tête il marque une perte de
30 mille dollars le actuellement sur une
vendre c'est énorme on peut pas vivre
comme ça longtemps puis contenu que moi
je cela ferme ici j'en sors une une à
deux par mois
pour leur part les pertes dans le veau
de grain sont autour de 100 dollars
l'animal mais avec deux fois plus
d'animaux en élevage le manque à gagner
à la ferme de monsieur beaudoin est
impressionnant pour nous d'alphonse ces
satrapes mail pour la période qu'on a
perdu dalphond 130 mille dollars de
sorties à peu près 1300 vaut pas la
période du confinement
le veau est apprécié des communautés
culturelles
mais la corrida frappé à la fin de
l'hiver des bulles des fêtes religieuses
en temps normal un moment fort puis
cette amibe est le ramadan est arrivé en
plein dans la crise et c'est une grosse
c'est une grosse période pour les
secteurs second degré quant à comparer
le ramadan on perd une partie de notre
marché
à partir du mois de juin les épiceries
ont pris le relais pour écouler un
certain volume de vos comme les clubs
les côtelettes ou le voit chez mais très
peu de place pour les coupes plus haut
de gamme
de plus en plus parler d'achat local
puis du fait qu' on est vraiment un
produit local
on devrait se retrouver vraiment plus en
épicerie mais je pense que c'est
accessible pour monsieur tout le monde
si la personne est capable de l'acheter
au resterait qu'une consommation peas
fait pourquoi que ça se ferait pas à la
maison c'est faisable
on a vu plein de jafar du pays c'est un
banal confinement bombay puis soudain
escalope de veau de grain ou faire du
pain et sait pas vraiment plus compliqué
[Musique]
pierre luc nadeau est un éleveur est
dépendant
il pourrait toujours choisir d'acheter
moins de jeunes veaux et réduire son
élevage
mais c'est risqué il espère que la
réouverture des restaurants amène une
embellie pour le veau de lait dans les
années normales statique mais là où tant
de ces gros marché ça me coûte un peu
diminué non aux entrées de vaud parce
qu'aussi qui à l'automne c'est bon il
reste que l'énorme volume qui a été
congelé devra sortir du congélateur ya
le contexte soucis qu'on voit arriver ce
qu'on appelle un mur de viande on risque
d'avoir une crise qui va s'éterniser le
si on accumule les crocos ont rempli les
congélateurs de viande ça veut dire
qu'une reprise dans le secteur pourrait
être très longue
[Musique]
pour les éleveurs structure et l'élevage
du veau et devenir leader dans le
nord-est de l'amérique a demandé
beaucoup d'efforts ils ont mis quarante
ans pour l'instant il résiste aux
impacts de l'aco vide mais ça ne doit
pas s'éterniser
on espère que la crise dans le néant les
personnes qui gardent répondre à une
question qu'est ce que ça va être trop
mou fait c'est un peu c'est un peu
embêtant avec son avis que les gens or
le groupe savoie de fêter de se réunir
afin que les gens ont le goût de bien
manger de se payer des choses un peu
différent que moi j'ai pas confiance
[Musique]